according to everybody the last exorcism
to is a pretty awful film you see there
are probably two people in this role
that actually liked the movie I happen
to be one of them I grew up with a
strong religious catholic upbringing so
anything to do with the devil scares the
[ __ ] out of me you see this room is just
loaded with a bunch of ideas that don't
fully meet its potential and if you're a
fan of the first movie you'll probably
be let down especially if you compare
the two but how is this film on its own
merits well the jump-scares seem pretty
force or they come from flashing footage
from the previous film a lot of the time
you might find yourself going shits
about to get crazy but then it doesn't
the tone is not the most upbeat the film
takes itself way too seriously the plot
moves at a weird case it shut really
well even though the script isn't that
good but overall I enjoyed this flick
I'm not a huge fan of most horror films
but here's what I have to say I can go
on and on about the film's flaws there's
a lot of them but what I did like was i
found the main character played by
ashley bell to be very entertaining I
cared a lot for her her emotions are
very believable and because of her I
didn't want the demon to win most of the
film seems to be somewhat of a character
study of her as she tries to lead a
born-again life but it's haunted by her
past or is it a demon even though the
film doesn't say full advantage of its
character study potential I actually
found the film to be a lot of fun they
have you jump a few times they kept my
interest throughout and I love the last
few minutes of this movie so even though
this one has more cons than pros by the
end of the film it all made sense I love
the first time a lot so I enjoyed just
seeing the story continued even though
they don't wrap up a few things from the
original and they practically drop the
whole thing about a cult I guess the
reason I enjoyed it was because I have
like no expectations for this film you
see if you even have a little bit of
expectations you'll be disappointed but
if you have no expectations you might
find it to be okay not going on
technical filmmaking but purely going
off in my feelings I would have to say
the last exorcism part 2 got it right
you
ladies and gentlemen go ahead and tell
me your points below and if you like the
video like the video and if you want to
see more reviews go ahead and subscribe
to my channel if you want to see an
extended review of the last exorcism
part to go ahead and check out my show
with my buddy Jerry called reasons to
see